The Real Reason Why Children Get the Summer
Off of School
The commonly touted explanation for students
having summers off from school dates back
to a time when the United States’ economy
relied heavily on agriculture in order to
survive.
Students needed to leave school in the summer
in order to work on the farm alongside their
families.
The U.S. is no longer the agrarian nation
that it once was, so why do students still
get the summer off from school?
Well, that is because the idea that the modern
school year is based off of one where students
needed to work on the farm during the summer
is false.
The majority of farming work occurs in either
the spring or fall, so schools in rural parts
of the United States during and before the
early part of the 19th century typically only
held classes during the winter and summer
months.
This allowed students time off to help plant
in the spring and harvest and sell crops in
the fall, and then they attended classes when
their families had less of a need for them
to work.
All in all, students in rural schools attended
between five and six months of school per
year.
On the other hand, schools serving students
in urban areas tended to remained open all
year with short breaks between academic quarters.
But most states did not require students to
attend school until the 1870s, so classes
often suffered from poor attendance.
Some school officials in Brooklyn reported
that only about half of their students attended
at least six months of classes during 1850.
A number of factors, such as practicality
and parent wishes, transformed those two different
types of school years into the school year
of today.
Education reformers encouraged both urban
and rural schools to adopt a standardized
school year in order to get students across
the country on the same school schedule.
This would make distributing standardized
tests and selling textbooks easier, among
other things.
But a standardized school year meant that
rural and urban school officials needed to
compromise on when to hold classes.
At this point it was generally thought that
holding classes throughout the year could
be detrimental to students’ health, so the
schools needed to decide on when to allow
students a break from classes.
The break would also give teachers time to
continue their own education and get ready
for the new school year.
Summer became a natural choice for a term
away from school.
Rural schools tended to be taught by teenage
girls in their mid- to late-teens in the summer,
leading to a weaker term than in the winter
when students learned under older and more
experienced schoolmasters.
Summer also worked for urban schools due to
the lack of air conditioning and the desires
of upper class and wealthy families to vacation
during those hot months.
The added worry of a school that was both
hot and crowded potentially spreading a disease
also added to the decision to give students
summers off from school.
Today, there is a movement among some educators
and politicians to restructure the school
year so that students attend classes throughout
the year.
The claim is that getting rid of summer vacation
would help students to perform on the same
academic level as students from other countries
by allowing for more hours of instruction.
However, when the numbers are crunched, American
students appear to be spending the same amount
of time learning per year as students elsewhere
in the world, at least in classes.
For instance, students from Massachusetts,
New York, California, Florida, and Texas all
spend 900 hours per year in school.
Comparatively, students in India receive between
800 and 900 hours of in-school education per
year, while students in China receive 900
hours.
Also contrary to the idea that more hours
are the answer, one of the highest rated education
systems in the world, Finland, only has their
students averaging about 608 hours of in-class
instruction per year.
As you might have guessed from this, as with
just about everything, the issues at hand
resists such simplistic explanations and solutions.
There is even a strong argument that students
in the U.S., on the whole, aren’t nearly
as far behind as is often claimed, though
of course there’s always vast room for improvement.
For instance, the Programme for International
Student Assessment (PISA) assesses the competencies
of 15-year-olds in 65 countries and economies,
including in math.
For 2012, the country/economy with the highest
scores in math was Shanghai-China, which was
closely followed by Singapore, Hong Kong-China,
Chinese Taipei and South Korea.
Notably, Canada ranked 13th, Australia 19th,
Ireland 20th and the United Kingdom 26th.
The United States’ kids ranked 36th.
In fact, according to PISA, the performance
of one of the United States’ highest-scoring
states, Massachusetts, was so low, it was
as if those students had two fewer years of
mathematical education than the students in
Shanghai-China.
PISA also noted that although the U.S. spends
more per student than most countries, this
doesn’t translate into performance.
In 2012, per-student spending in the U.S.
was listed at $115,000, while in the Slovak
Republic, a country that performed at the
same level, they spend only $53,000 per student.
However, the PISA’s results are drastically
over simplified.
For instance, as noted in a report by Dr.
Martin Carnoy of Stanford and Richard Rothstein
of the Economic Policy Institute, American
students actually perform better than the
much higher ranked Finland in algebra in general,
but worse in fractions.
More importantly, when you normalize the results
between the countries, adjusting for the relative
poverty of the students taking the PISA tests,
the U.S performs significantly better, ranking
6th in reading and 13th in mathematics, a
drastic jump in both categories.
Dr. Carnoy and Rothstein further note in their
report What Do International Tests Really
Show About U.S. Student Performance? that
when you divide the kids based on family wealth,
the actual gap in performance isn’t so stark
between any country, with a not insignificant
portion of the ultimate ranking of each nation
being based on how many impoverished vs. middle
class vs. wealthy students are taking the
tests.
For reference, about 40% of the schools the
PISA used in the U.S.’s sample had more
than 50% of their students eligible for free
lunch.
So what about switching to year round schooling
with extra hours spent in the classroom?
Will it help?
After all, even if the U.S. isn’t so far
behind as is often claimed, that doesn’t
mean improvements shouldn’t be sought.
Year round schooling has been tried several
times in the last few decades in the U.S.,
such as efforts in Texas in the 1990s (peaking
at about 400 year-round schools) and California
in the 1980s (peaking at well over 500 schools
on this type of schedule).
The results were underwhelming.
Test scores did not improve, attendance problems
were an issue at times (with families still
taking vacations, but now with students taking
off school at random times), and teachers
themselves were burning out (at a faster rate
than normal) with little spare time to pursue
required continuing education.
Beyond the extra training outside of work
hours (along with grading, course planning,
corresponding with parents, etc. that also
generally doesn’t fall within paid hours),
as one educator, Heather Wolpert-Gawron, noted,
“Adult humans aren’t built to spend their
days with hundreds of children each day.
It takes a lot out of an adult to have their
antennae up so high, so often, and so consistently.”
Beyond the teachers (and presumably students),
parents also tended not to like the switch,
due to cutting into family life and making
vacations difficult to manage.
In the end, in the late 1980s when California
schools that had made the switch were given
the option to return to a more traditional
“summer off” schedule, 543 of 544 year-round
schools chose to do so.